Excuse me, master and lady!
Moka moka!
Moka moka moka moka moka moka moka moka!
The shirt!
Oh yeah, you noticed.
Oh, it's kind of wobbly.
That's better.
Love your shirt!
You guys, I ordered it from like...
So you know when you order something from like Amazon?
And then it comes...
And it's like...
Like a baby, you know?
You think you're ordering something, but then they just put it on a t-shirt?
I thought I was ordering a t-shirt and then...
I thought...
Instead, it was not a PNG shirt.
It was a JPEG shirt!
I kind of got scammed.
I ordered a PNG t-shirt, but instead...
A JPEG t-shirt came.
Yeah, like...
Like when people order like...
A bedroom set, and then it's a poster of a bedroom.
Oh well.
I'll still wear it.
I think it looks good on me anyway.
I was able to get the holo tickets.
Oh, is that today?
I'm not going.
I thought I would go, but...
I have too much going on in August.
Have fun for me!
But...
Oh!
Congrats on getting the tickets!
Also, Lost in the Store, they give you the 10 gifted!
And Curry Ninja, they give you the 5 gifted!
Thank you, thank you!
Not a fan of those wet pee shirts that are popping up recently.
I can...
I see the problem.
The seam doesn't connect to the collar, so the white filled took up the whole box.
Oh...
You're right!
Oh gosh.
They just don't make things like they used to anymore.
But anyway!
Welcome!
This will be a pretty short stream.
I just got home, like...
An hour ago.
And I was like...
I must...
I must watch this...
Watch along.
I must do it.
Or I must do a watch along of this.
Because...
I've been waiting all day.
How was your trip?
It was good!
It was...
I actually...
I will not say anything about it right now.
You will hear about it eventually.
Hopefully within like a week.
I got paid.
So I'm here to pay the mint phantom tax.
There's no tax!
Thank you for the super tapichi!
I love magnesium sulfide too.
What a coinkydink.
Saving it for the podcast?
I'm saving it.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
Which actually...
We got to record that tomorrow.
Hold on.
Let me message Metara.
You...
You still...
Still good for the podcast.
Tomorrow.
Recording.
Haruka!
Thank you for the...
Gifted.
Thank you!
Heard something about tax?
No!
Hello boss.
Good to have you.
Oh my god.
Why is there so much...
What's happening?
Tax?
No, no, no!
What's happening?
Why are there so many super tax?
All of a sudden.
Matthews.
Thank you.
Nerdy.
Delerant.
Thank you.
Spark.
Thank you guys.
Okay.
I know nothing of this.
So basically, Konami had this Metal Gear production hotline number one.
So we're going to be getting more than one of these.
Which is kind of crazy.
And it's only like 20 minutes long as you can see.
I don't know at all.
What we'll be talking about.
Stop!
Watch along V.
And...
But I think they will be talking about Metal Gear.
And I like that.
So I'm going to watch it.
Will it even be in English?
It literally says in the title with English subtitles.
So you're good.
You're Gooch.
You're Gucci.
You're all good.
No worries.
Okay.
We are done.
Just a minute.
I just heard about the midfed.
The Murad.
Oh my gosh you guys.
Stop!
I'm Furphy.
Thanks for the vibe gifted.
Oh my gosh, TK.
Thank you for the ping.
Don't worry guys, I've got the tags this time.
Stop!
Sayonara!
Okane!
Watch a long ticket.
This is getting out of hand, man.
This is getting out of hand.
I would like to watch this now, please.
May I?
May I watch this?
I've been waiting patiently all day.
Bravo Chief, thanks for the 5k.
Choco Minto, tax, tax, tax!
Minto stinky?
I'm starting.
I'm ignoring you guys now.
She hates our money.
This is my tax refund.
I ain't paying my taxes.
It's 20 minutes and 57 seconds for you.
Well, look at you living in 2035.
We're all here in 2024.
That's when they introduced that they can edit videos.
And they added in one extra second to say...
Frick roll!
Can you imagine?
That's what they put in.
The extra second is what it says.
Good bit, boss.
Shut up!
I love MSG.
No, no!
Okay, you scared me for a second.
I thought I accidentally wrote that.
I mean, bought that.
What if I got a shirt that says I heart MSG?
I believe that it exists.
Mint tax.
Remember to let go all those nerd energy.
Nerd energy.
I do love MSG though.
You know what?
Me too.
I like MSG also.
Makes things taste real delicious.
Okay, so yeah.
They're just gonna talk...
We're just gonna react to this.
Sorry, I'm a react YouTuber now.
Stop!
Thank you for the pink lost!
Mint tax.
This is ridiculous.
I hope you're happy.
Madison Square Garden.
No, no, no, no.
That would be the MSG.
Madison Garden Square.
They renamed it.
To fix the...
Like, you know, they misprinted all of these t-shirts.
They were like, we can't sell this.
There's nothing in the world called MGS.
And so, they were like, we'll just rename it from Madison Square Garden to Madison Garden Square.
TK, thank you for the 50 adopts.
Thank you.
What the heck?
Thank you so much!
I wanna talk about my trip.
But I will refrain.
I will refrain.
And I'll talk about it another day.
Because right now...
Metal Gear time.
OK.
Let me turn off my music.
TA-DA!
Let me turn the volume up here.
Let me move out of the way.
I'm gonna cover you guys so everybody can see my cool shirt here.
I'll even... There we go.
I want everybody to see my cool shirt.
Why are you guys sending so much DocTalk?
It is E-O-F-Y.
What is that?
Wait, what does that mean?
Embodiment of Phantomir.
Oh,
end of fiscal year!
Oh, I got the year part right.
I'm such a genius.
End of Phantomir.
No!
And then I just disintegrate like Thanos snapped me out of existence.
We love our ghostly, bustin' mind and our obsession with tactical espionage action.
Oh my gosh, my bag shipped.
My, my, my metal bag shipped.
Oh, gear bag.
I'm so excited.
I heart MGS.
Mint ghost streamer.
Let me guys, let me know, let me, let me know guys if you would like this as official, um, official t-shirt merch.
It would not be a t-shirt that says I heart MGS.
It would be a t-shirt of this t-shirt that says I heart MGS.
A t-shirt of a t-shirt.
I haven't watched this either.
I hope it's cool.
I hope so too!
I'm excited to hear more stuff about Delta.
And like I said, I don't really know what else.
I think some people were speculating that there might be talks of the Master Collection number 2.
So maybe.
We'll see.
I don't know.
Everything's a mystery.
I heart MF.
Are you a MF?
Are you a MF-er?
Hmm.
MGS4, please.
I know, right?
Alright.
Are you guys ready?
There's not really a countdown because I'm just gonna play it on the screen.
But, um...
We'll watch it.
It's only 20 minutes and then we can talk more afterwards.
Sound good?
Ready?
We are MF-er!
It's me.
I'm MF-er.
Okie dokie!
Sounds good.
Okie dokie.
I'm just gonna play it and I can adjust the audio as we go.
Give me one second too.
Ok.
It needs to be a mint ghost solid t-shirt.
With you in a liquid snake co- Why am I in a liquid snake costume?
You're just trying to get me shirtless.
You sneaky!
I see right through your plans.
Baby car!
Thanks for the gift.
Okie dokie.
Are we good now?
Yeah, Liquid, you guys, is naked.
I mean, not naked.
He has no shirt on.
Please God, Peace Walker on Master Collection Part 2.
Alright, let's start.
We won't...
My next video is busted.
No way.
That's so funny.
It knows.
It really does know.
Ok.
Metal Gear Production Hotline.
I wonder why they started...
It started.
Metal Gear Production Hotline.
Oh, let me move the...
This show is brought to you by Metal Gear Solid Delta Snake Eater's latest information, questions from viewers, and questions from fans.
My questions.
Oh my god, it's the opening!
Is it the... oh, look at all the credits.
Yoroshiku Onegai Itashimasu.
They're going so fast.
I cannot even think like I can comment.
Yoroshiku Onegai Itashimasu.
And this is the producer, Noriaki Okamura.
Please introduce yourself, Okamura-san.
I am the producer of the Metal Gear series, Okamura-san.
I sent this live stream to Okamura-san, Oishi-san.
And today, I would like to introduce one more person.
This is the creative producer, Yuji Korekado.
Please introduce yourself.
I am Konami's Korekado.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, too.
I have worked on many Metal Gear series.
I was the director of the second Metal Gear Online series.
I was the producer of the Metal Gear Rising series and the Metal Gear Survival series.
I am also the creative producer of the Metal Gear Delta series.
Thank you very much.
Oishi-san, the production hotline has started.
How is the audio?
I will turn it up just a little bit.
The instrumental is making me emotional.
First reveal!
Technical previews!
It's good?
Okay.
Yeah.
You read that script.
Wait, what does the SE stand for?
Metal Gear?
Oh, Snake Eater.
Oh, gosh.
I'm so scared.
Never mind.
Editor, cut that from the VOD, please.
Special edition.
As soon as I, like, said it, then it just...
Oh, it came to me.
Oh, this is the one that they showed before, right?
Oh, it looks so good.
Oh, paramedic looks so cute.
They added, like, the lens flare from Five.
It's a snake.
Where's the pee filter?
It's toggleable.
They've already said that.
That's gonna be me.
Oh, my gosh.
I love...
I love that the Croc mouth kind of opens and closes.
It's so cute.
Ew!
God, he's gross!
Oh, my gosh.
I bet he tastes like a wild beast.
One man army.
God.
Okay, the one thing is he better do his little flips in the air.
I swear.
They took that out of the patchy slot game.
Speak.
Oh, there he is.
The
boss!
Oh, it's such a good trailer!
Oh, it's so good!
Did they... for the Japanese, actually I don't...
Yeah!
I do like it.
Gonna play with Japanese voices?
No, no.
Gonna play with the English voices.
It is really good in Japanese, though.
But... I love the English.
Dubbed so much.
Yeah!
Metal Gear Production Hotline!
It's like one of those rare series that I play in English, you know?
They speak English canonically?
They're speaking Russian sometimes.
Visual.
Look at that little crocodile!
Oh my god, the Russian jungles.
Little crab!
He's a frog!
We've seen all these, though.
Oh, the Easter Delta signify change.
Mm.
Bullet holes!
Look at how muddy he is.
Ah!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he's actually got, like, bullet holes and stuff!
Oh!
Crouch!
Crouch walking!
Yippee!
They only added that to Metal Gear Solid, or to MGS3.
Ah!
They only added it in the 3DS version.
But playing this game on the 3DS is, uh...
Oh!
Wait!
Oh my god.
Wait, who's asking for this?
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Wait.
It's like...
Not kissy enough.
I think.
He's asking for full...
Full stuff-ia mode.
.
Black and white.
The...
The Instagram filter really gets me, though.
.
I think it's been a long time.
Really, it looks like they're paying attention to the criticisms, which I think is good, too.
Why are there more people saying it's very bad over bad?
Oh, goodness.
So they were like, it was fine, but we want to see more, for the most part.
Oh, my God.
This is mucho texto.
People tend to choose extreme options.
I guess that's true.
Especially, I don't know, Japan's kind of...
Even the bad and negative, you can't even do a simple remaster, right?
Metal Gear is dead and you're the ones who killed it?
Oh, my God.
They're brave.
This is...
This is a level of self-awareness that I did not expect to see from them.
Oh, my God.
I love it.
I'm giving you the benefit of the doubt.
They're taking that as positive and not neutral.
Give us English subs.
This is a brave conference.
I respect this a lot, actually.
I think I respect this a lot.
More so than just like, you know, kind of like, you know.
Thinking they're the shit, you know?
They kind of realize that people are...
Being very critical of them.
... being very critical of them.
.
I'm doing years of bed.
They are dedicated.
I think it helps that you have so many...
or rather you have a handful of people from the original.
So they understand how important this is.
Like the original devs or team.
Team.
Aren't there already?
Maybe they are saying outside the company.
They would come back.
Of course, if I were to talk about myself, I would like to work with the staff, including Kojima-san.
Do you want to say that?
But many people are already on the new path.
And among them, the fact that they are cooperating with us, is a prerequisite.
Because they have a bright future and an independent future.
I think that we are the ones who should do that.
I think we should do our best to be able to be highly evaluated.
I think that we should do our best to be able to be highly evaluated.
And we have a question that you guys often ask about, I think the name of Kojima-san...
Master Collection is the next Delta...
Oh my god!
Wait, so they're going to be also in...
They're going to be credited in Delta?
Oh my god!
Oh, okay, so the Japanese is also the same.
Yippee!
So they had to probably redo some of that stuff.
That makes sense, though.
Oh!
AI?
Oh my gosh, Grammy!
Thanks for the request!
Did you watch this already?
But it's not uncommon for them to have, like, a bunch of recorded lines and stuff, and...
Mix and match stuff.
I don't know.
Who knows if it's AI?
Oh, you guys are the gifters.
Yeah, splicing, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's so cute!
Really?
To buy a box engine?
.
But also, if the person is, like, you know...
Not available and that they are not of this realm anymore, I don't think it can be helped.
.
I'm curious about the series, but...
Oh!
I pre-ordered that!
I'm so excited, I love the art for it so much.
I'm excited to just display it.
Put me on the box, just like the pause.
I always recommend MGS3 first.
I can't!
Because...
Because basically...
I think of it also how the technology advances, you know?
Going from MGS3 to MGS1?
Or MGS3?
MGS5 to MGS1?
It's just so much.
In terms of like...
You know, other...
If you go and really sort or...
Improv!
Cushion!
Oh my god!
Not the tumblers!
I'm sorry, I love...
Oh my god, they're so cute!
No!
Oh my god!
October?
I won't be there!
Oh my god!
Sorry!
They're so cute!
No!
Oh my goodness!
What the hell is this thing!?
.
We will post the link in the description box or on Metal Gear X official website.
We are looking forward to your comments.
So, this is the first episode of the Metal Gear production hotline.
How was it?
We will tell you more information next time.
And...
Actually, there is one more thing.
Wait, before we go, it's almost over?
This is the background.
This is the background of the title screen.
This is the opening image of the Metal Gear Solid Delta Snake Eater.
We introduced this as a new opening image last time.
The original Snake Eater is also included.
So, it's either one?
Yes.
Can I see more of the game?
I explained the new style and the legacy style.
The new style is for the Zungle title.
Thank you.
If you play the legacy style, you will be able to see the old title.
So, each one is different.
Okay.
We are looking forward to the new information next time.
This is the end of the Metal Gear production hotline.
See you next time.
Thank you.
That's it?
Too short.
Oh my God!
It looks so good!
Man!
I wanted to see more of the game.
What
is this?
I was hoping to see more of the game.
Oh, wow.
I don't remember what music I had before.
I think it was this one.
Maybe.
Do I have to do frame by frame analysis now?
Hold on.
Actually, I do want to go back to these plushies.
Sorry.
Let me go back to these plushies.
Where are they?
Where are the plushies?
Bustin' is up.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Where are they?
Oh my gosh.
And a floor!
You guys!
I'm not even kidding you.
You know those places where you can, like...
Okay.
So, there's sometimes places...
Hold on.
Everybody needs to see my t-shirt.
There are places where you can, like, go and make your own rug.
You basically, like, bring in a design and they print it out for you.
And then they help you, like...
And you make it yourself.
You're like...
And I was gonna do that with the Foxhound logo, but I was like, there's no way.
Like, it's too detailed.
It wouldn't look good.
But I really wanted it.
But now I can just get a mad end-up cushion!
I don't really care about the newer Foxhound logo.
I care about middle Foxhound logo.
I like this one.
I like this one the most.
I think it's the most iconic.
It's official, too.
I know!
Thank you so much for the 5k update!
Oh, hold on.
This one...
The tumblers!
Wait, so is it...
Oh, yes!
Okay, so this must be the front and the back.
And then you have MGS1, 2, and 3.
But the original metal...
Look at the original metal gear!
Okay, what the hell is going on?
Are there, like, three rays there?
They look so cute, though!
Yeah, you can see the shagohan kind of peeking out from the corner.
Little Godly is such a pixel man!
Oh my gosh!
Raiden is a skinny legend here.
What's up with that?
Rex Ray and the shagohan.
Yeah!
The rays...
Yeah, it's interesting, though, that they put multiple.
I mean, I guess you do fight multiple.
It's just funny.
Oh...
Before the thickening.
I can't wait to drink out of these and only these.
Actually, no.
I own some metal gear mugs.
It's 2, 3, and Peace Walker, I believe, are the only three that they released.
And I don't use them, though.
I keep them in my cabinet.
Or rather, in my store.
Like, I keep them with my Metal Gear collection.
These are shot glasses.
No, I think these are, like, full-sized tumblers.
Like a regular cup.
Stainless steel tumbler.
Yeah.
Printed with iterations of Metal Gear and Snake.
And the other characters hiding in the rivers.
And...
I think they wereorned?
I
think they wereorned.
And I think I saw little rouge in them and it's just...
They were quantinin- Oh, there's some music.
They're so cute.
Oh my gosh, their little feet sticking out.
I can't wait.
Wait, I wonder how big they are.
I'm gonna waste all my money at the claw machines.
They're so cute.
I love plushies.
Pocket-sized?
I can't tell.
If they're pocket-sized, I'm gonna have to get like 50 of them.
Don't cry, boys.
I can't help it.
That was the last thing, right?
And then, at the beginning here too...
They were talking about the stains and battle damage.
Yeah, the leaves.
It was like...
It's so great.
And he's got...
Look at that guy right there!
I love crocodiles.
They have a box of tissues at their desk for the next episode.
Why is it doing that though when he's walking by?
Look how gross he looks!
Oh my god, he's a muddy man!
Raindrop.
Choco Chip is back!
Go to naked.
Yippee!
The vein!
Snake...
Snake, you look cold.
Put on a t-shirt, please.
I offer you the shirt off my back.
Cover those up, sir, please!
Wait, he needs to be disinfected.
Actually, they are covered.
No nip...
No nip slips for you guys.
He is covered, actually.
He's a modest man.
Oh my god, he looks...
I can't stop!
I need to stop!
Even his back!
Oh my god.
He looks so good.
Ocelot's gonna freak!
He's such a tease.
Kyaa!
New style.
How did he know where to aim that thing?
I can't believe we can crouch run though now.
I don't know.
What do you guys think of the filter?
Like the...
I guess it does look pretty similar to the old...
To the original.
Now that I'm...
You know...
I think it just looks jarring to me because...
I think it looks jarring to me at first because like...
I'm used to seeing it...
This color...
In...
You know...
Not high def graphics.
Yeah, too much detail.
I think it could be...
I think it looks a little dark.
Maybe that's it.
Like it could be a little bit brighter and a little bit more yellow-y.
But also we're only seeing it in like...
Minimal scenes.
You know?
So...
So we don't know.
It could be...
It could look better in like...
You know...
But also...
Who is...
Who?
Who is making this?
Who asked for this?
I like this!
Such a lust for Sepia!
Whoo!
Sepia?
I'm really curious how H.D.Ocelot will look meowing.
No, right?
If you wanna feel like...
Old cat, like...
Oh!
This is like...
You know...
You were like...
Oh my gosh!
I actually called Konami personally for this.
You did it!
Best filter.
Okay, this one I can forgive.
It's this one.
It's Instagram Yasified Snake that I don't know what to do with.
My eyes!
It says retro, but it's literally...
It's literally... they're gonna have like speedruns for like the different... speedrun sepia, speedrun retro filter.
This is just an Instagram filter though.
We do have multiple color filters you can change between, applicable whether you are playing new style or legacy style.
One option closely recreates the original palette so you can play with your preferred look.
So what was it?
Okay, hold on.
So this... oh, nope, that's not normal.
That's not normal, that's not normal!
This is normal.
And then...
No!
Why are you lying to me?
This is legacy.
I'm trying to go back.
I'm trying to go back and forth more quickly, but it's like the little preview is lying to me.
You see that?
Normal.
Legacy.
J and L.
Oh, wow!
What?
And that... hold on, let me pull up a picture.
Metal Gear Solid 3.
Just so I can have like a visual...
In my face visual.
Let's see.
Let me pick...
Lighter greens.
Hold on.
Let's see.
I'm just trying to find a screenshot of him like standing in the forest.
Snake Eater.
Ahem.
I don't want to use this picture, but it might be the best thing.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I'm trying to find a decent picture to pull up on the screen.
Maybe this one.
Thank you!
Have you seen the edit where someone put David Hader and Laurie Allen's face?
I did!
Where they put him on the snake and the boss.
It does look really good.
I have seen it.
Okay.
So this is what we have.
And this is what it is like.
I think it only looks...
It actually is pretty accurate.
I think again, it only looks different because...
Well, actually the one from the original...
The original one looks a little bit more blue-hued.
But I think it's just because it's higher def, it looks different.
Yeah.
Less foggy.
Mmm.
The color is actually pretty accurate.
Pretty similar.
And then when you compare it to...
The normal?
Yeah!
Again, I think it's like the fog and the...
Just the blurriness of like the PS...
You know, the PS2.
So...
That's gonna...
You know...
That's just...
It's just lower quality.
I think there's more blue hints...
Blue hues rather...
In the...
In the original though.
From what I can see.
Oops, sorry.
Can we get an option?
We get a lower poly?
I know!
That would be so fun!
That would be a really good like camo to have.
Or...
You know how like at the beginning...
You're just like...
I like MGS3.
I like MGS2.
I like Metal Gear Solid.
You know how you can pick that?
At the beginning?
If you pick...
I like Metal Gear Solid 3.
That...
It gives you...
Um...
A mask that...
Has Snake's PS2 face.
I think would be funny.
Can't wait to play with the retro filter.
Hmm...
Yeah...
So it's not so...
It's actually pretty...
Accurate.
And it does say that they're...
You know...
They're...
Re...
Closely recreating the original game.
I think they...
I mean that was a huge people...
A huge complaint from people so...
Andragos thanks for the 10 gifted!
This though...
Hold on...
Also...
We skipped over...
Some...
Where's the...
This is...
Where's the Shitsumon corner?
Oh...
It was after...
Wait...
Here...
Is there any chance that the original staff members will return to work on co-develop or supervise any of the Metal Gear series?
This...
I bit my tongue...
Hello?
I'm...
Shocked...
It's not my place to answer these questions.
I don't want to answer on behalf of anyone outside of the company...
Or to guess how they might feel about it...
But just speaking for myself personally...
But they...
But...
The fact that...
Konami allowed him to say this...
Really surprises me...
You know?
To work with Kojima and the rest of the team again...
If that could happen...
That would be a dream...
That's insane!
I wonder how Kojima-san feels about that...
I just want to hear Sigan ask me why I'm naked when I call him...
And he will...
Patience...
I'm very...
Very curious...
Up until now, it seemed like they tried to do everything to not say Kojima...
Yeah...
Ummm...
I...
I see comments in the chat...
And I will not... read them.
You guys have your own opinions... and such.
I... would like to one day be sponsored.
So I... I will just say that this...
this is probably the most shocking thing...
of the whole hotline.
But my favorite part...
is... not him.
Sorry.
This chat loves Konami!
Yippee!
I only just realized we can spin Snake.
Oh yeah!
Can we spin Snake and make him sick in the menu?
I sure hope so, oh my gosh.
I wanna make him barf.
I wanna make this man barf.
Look, look, look.
This is a guy who's ready to barf.
That's a good question to send.
I think, yeah.
I think maybe a good question would be...
how much... how many features from the game will be...
kept...
in the remake?
Such as like, you know, that.
And what new features will they be...
I guess they can't say what new...
Or rather...
Will the old features be kept?
And will any new features be added?
You know?
I think what people...
When you talk about, you know...
When you talk about the relationship...
Between...
Both companies...
Both parties, rather.
I think...
First of all...
Literally no one in this chat was there.
And also...
You know, time...
I think...
Times are different, and so...
You can't always think that...
Opinions that once were, are the same.
Actually...
I'm John Konami.
So...
I don't know.
I'm more of an optimist, I suppose.
In that regard.
Where I feel like that relationships...
Because, you know...
I've...
You know...
I've had friendships end and then rekindle.
So I think that...
Relationships...
Between things can...
Be salvaged.
So...
That's my opinion on stuff.
That's all.
You know.
And people like money.
So true!
And I think...
With Kojima-san...
He's definitely still loves Metal Gear.
He's always retweeting stuff about it.
And tweeting stuff himself about it.
So...
You know.
I would never...
I would not say...
You know, never say never.
So...
Yeah.
That's all.
I like money too!
Oh my gosh!
What a co-winky thing.
But yeah.
So...
You're saying professional relationships can bloom even in the border.
Perhaps.
I don't know about love though.
Contractual.
Something.
Contractual love.
Thank you.
Is there such thing as an absolute timeless enemy?
There's no such thing and never has been.
And the reason is that our enemies are human beings like us.
They can only be our enemies in relative terms.
So Metal Gear.
But...
Will the movement be the same as MGS5?
It's hard to say.
They probably will be the same as MGS4.
They didn't show us anything.
They just said that there's remake mode and then there's...
There's remake mode and then there's...
Legacy mode.
But also...
I didn't see... What do they include in this timeline?
We've seen this before though, right?
This is on the website.
Where's Snake's Revenge?
That's the real Metal Gear 2!
Where is it?
Mint becomes a Metal Gear news channel?
Feels a little like that, huh?
She likes money!
Get her!
Where's Portable Ops?
Yeah, they actually didn't put in Portable Ops.
No Ghost Babble, no Portable Ops.
I mean, Acid of course wouldn't be in here, but...
Yeah, where's Ape Escape?
No Rising?
Well, Rising makes sense because...
This is a Metal Gear Solid timeline.
And that's Metal Gear Rising.
Not Metal Gear Solid.
So you can take that one to the bank.
Metal Gear Rising 2.
Metal Gear Solid Delta Peace Walker.
I wonder... I do feel like they'll continue making these.
But also...
I don't know.
I don't know how I'd feel about it.
About them doing it.
I mean, they don't need to do all the games, obviously.
Like, Phantom Pain is totally fine.
Even I'd say MGS4 is fine.
I hate money.
Get away from me, money!
Rule of nature.
And then, they did also say that, you know, the old team and Kojima's name will be...
I don't know.
It was kind of confusing.
They said it was for the Master Collection, but...
They didn't really mention if it was for Delta.
They kind of scooted around that one.
Do you think it was braver to name drop Kojima or MGS4 5?
I think this whole...
This thing... This whole...
This whole hotline... I don't even know what to call it.
This whole segment was so brave.
Like, the questions...
Like, this...
This!
Metal Gear is dead and you're the ones who killed it!
Like, wow!
Wow!
And then, they took that comment and put it on the screen!
They probably received, like, thousands of comments.
And they were like, man, this one really...
This one's really tell...
And then they read it out loud!
I know!
It just felt like...
With the negative ones, it just felt like arrow after arrow after...
Also, this one.
Based.
They actually let us type whatever we want here.
Wait, I didn't see that one the first time!
Oh, my God!
That's so funny!
Who had to translate that for them?
But, it's funny because the positive ones are so, like...
Like, kind of neutral.
I feel like you really do care, so I'm giving you the benefit of the doubt.
It's like, don't fuck it up, you guys!
Seeing Konami be ready to talk so openly with the fans is really great.
This one's good.
This one's nice.
But it's also, like, kind of throwing shade, though.
Because they're just, like...
They're talking openly because everyone's shit-talking you guys!
How did they translate based in JP?
I can't read the kanji, so I can't tell you.
Bring on some of the other MGS Delta Snake Eater dev staff, too.
Can we see more gameplay or first reveal stuff?
Yeah, we didn't really see...
I guess first reveal stuff for this would be the survival menu.
That was kind of all we got.
English subs.
You should answer more questions at a time.
Base Dome.
Ah, I think, yeah.
And then, bugs that impact gameplay should have been fixed before release.
This is about the Master Collection, obviously.
You'll probably do a bad job on the next game, too.
So I'd rather you just gave up!
You can't even do a simple remaster, right?
No punches pulled.
What I like about them showing this, though, is that they are actually, like...
It seems that they will read this and be like, Okay, we'll prove them wrong.
You know?
Like with the Master Collection, it did...
When it first came out...
Saying that there were...
You know, you can't say that there were no issues.
But they have gone...
They have done so much to fix them.
And I believe that the Master Collection also kind of went above and beyond in what they offered.
In terms of, like, extra bonus stuff.
Like with the soundtracks and...
The, um...
Like, orchestral remakes of the songs and the scripts.
And adding, like...
You know...
Snake's Revenge.
...
So, there is...
I mean, obviously, it's positive and negative.
Yeah, the comics...
Like, they really...
It really...
Like, when they first were talking about it...
It felt like that they were putting out a lot of care.
And so...
You know...
When there were all the buggy issues with it...
And...
People...
Were rightfully upset.
You know?
But...
They're still working on it and it's not unusual right now for buggy releases to get left that way.
Showing this level of negativity is a sign of them trying to show their sincerity, I think.
That's how I feel about it too, right?
Like, I feel...
Like, this is...
This is...
These are really bad comments.
So, I actually respect it.
You know?
I actually respect that they kind of put that out there.
This is really bad.
And then this...
They just let us type whatever we want here.
And then they put it on the screen.
Then they choose it.
Oh my gosh.
What was this?
This is all kind of like...
Gone over pretty quickly.
And then even this.
What did you think of the March episode?
Only 52% said it was pretty good.
Like, we're very good.
Oh, information about Master Collection, Volume 2.
M.G.O.
Ni tsute.
Oh.
OK, there's nothing else.
Mm-mm.
Pretty good.
Why didn't they say...
Why didn't they translate it as pretty good?
Well, I mean, I guess, tottemo yokatto does not mean pretty good.
It means very good.
But, you know...
Come on!
Just do the joke!
It's a joke!
I don't know.
Do the joke!
It makes sense.
Yeah, what else would you like to see in the hotline?
New info.
Yeah, give me new info.
What would other be?
Maybe like, merchandise?
Which we did kind of get that.
They should give Revenge the twin snake style remake where the cutscenes are crazier and even more over the top.
Yeah!
Snake ducky.
Snake undies!
When are we getting this?
It was only released in Europe.
They released like a Shadow Moses perfume.
Oh wait, not perfume.
Cologne.
I tried to buy it, but I couldn't.
Snake fumo.
That reminds me.
I haven't checked AmiAmi today.
To see if...
Oh, my bad.
Don't look at my stuff!
To see if...
There was a new...
The snake figma is up yet.
There we go.
AmiAmi.
I love private email.
That's my business email.
Stop.
I told you don't look.
Wait, what is in here?
Amazon...
Why is that pinned?
Untinned.
I didn't put that there.
Here, I'll even read it to you, okay?
YouTube, private email, calendar, Twitter, X?
Why are they two separate things?
Google Drive, Studio, YouTube, and AmiAmi are my...
All my recent things, okay?
Oh wait, I'm not going to Twitter.
I instinctually...
I instinctually clicked Twitter.
Okay, AmiAmi.
Oh, my gosh!
AmiAmi!
Her figure is up for pre-order on here.
Okay, I'll pre-order it.
Wait a second.
Hold on, I want this.
You guys, hold on.
Wait.
Okay, good.
I'm not laughing.
I want that.
She's just licking the floor.
Here, look at the AmiAmi one.
It's kind of spicy.
It's not even that expensive.
It's actually a decent price.
It's actually pretty...
January 2025.
Sensei.
Where are we?
YouTube, don't flag me.
This is art.
It's artwork.
Pre-order fun.
Thank you.
What else is on here?
There's a REM.
Birthday cake REM.
Okay.
I think I've seen that one before.
Bye, bye, bye.
Yen is at an all-time low.
Still no snake though.
I'm not sure.
I don't see him at least.
The price.
Oh my god.
It's so expensive.
Look how cute her face is though.
It's really cute.
But I gotta figure.
That's um...
Hold on.
Hold on, I'll show you.
Let's see if I can find it even.
I wanted these two ones also.
This one.
I love how soft her hair looks.
And it's not a bad price.
Kana is the genius child who licks baking soda.
What is your special... I can't even read that word.
I'm the genius ghost who...
Who's always busting!
Yeah!
I'm the genius ghost who's always busting.
Let's see.
That was like some time ago.
They released so much Yudokan merch.
Sorry that it's all kind of cut off.
I don't feel like resizing.
I like how this is just delved into AmiAmi's stream.
Sorry.
It wasn't this long ago though.
I don't think.
Does that mean the order date is coming up?
It wasn't that long ago.
I just want to get the figure.
I just want the new Figma.
The new snake Figma.
Where is my figure that I ordered?
No Metal Gear merch?
I wonder actually.
Metal Gear...
You can see what I searched for before.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
Pekora.
Stop!
Don't call me out!
Get
out of the Metal Gear menu, you guys.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
It's all old stuff though.
I think this is like the only thing that you probably would be able to get.
Because... yeah.
They re-released it.
I feel like I'm being exposed in so many ways.
This is why I never window... or never...
Yeah, this is why I never show my windows.
I don't know.
I want...
Let's see.
I got one recently.
But it was second hand.
Let me see.
I think they have...
They should have it on here.
This.
I got this one.
Oh, no.
Just kidding.
Sorry.
Wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong.
No.
This one.
I got the Peace Walker...
Play...
Play Arts...
Figure.
So...
I got that second hand recently.
And I got the figure of Snake with the fat ass.
I'm so excited for that one.
Oh my gosh.
Look at him.
I need him.
I need this man.
Look at them standing next to each other.
Oh my God.
His glasses.
Look at him posing.
I need this guy.
Why doesn't he come with a hamburger?
The mask is a little kinky though.
I think.
I think the mask is a little...
Wow.
Why do the aviators look like poop?
What are you talking about?
They don't at all.
Also, I love...
You guys can't see it but I'm going to click on this.
And you're gonna be like, why was this under Metal Gear?
Like I know why.
Because of the title of the figure.
But it's also very funny.
It's because it's Symphogear.
And then the bunny suit is metallic red.
So it's under Metal Gear.
I don't remember her.
Oh, I have this Raiden.
I found him at a secondhand store before once.
In Japan.
I have this.
The...
I bought it from here actually.
I wanted the AmiAmi pass case.
So I have that.
Blame Otacon.
Yeah.
These are such good...
Like...
This is a really expensive one.
But these other figure prices are pretty decent.
Well, this one is expensive too but...
I have...
This one took me forever to find.
Symphogear Mansion.
This took me forever to find.
And I didn't want it in the black version.
I wanted it in the original version.
But I own this.
And...
Mine didn't come with stickers.
No.
I've been ripped off.
What?
Mine didn't come with stickers.
I've been robbed.
But it's...
I didn't want the one in black.
I wanted it in...
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I just opened up my phone because I was checking a notification.
But I was listening to...
TikTok.
I don't know if you heard it.
Mine didn't have stickers.
But also, I don't even see the stickers applied onto here.
So, what's the point?
Art book.
D-dog.
Guilty Gear.
Only hurt a little.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
This is the one I got.
Look how...
I had to get...
The...
Well, not the only reason.
But the biggest reason I wanted it was because of these guys.
I needed the tiny...
Look at his abs.
They're so small.
I had to have them.
And look how cute Rex is.
Oh my gosh.
It's one of...
I think it's one of the favorite things I own.
I wonder if they have...
A...
Oh, wow.
There's a Metal Gear Solid 3D...
Wait, what's this?
Oh, God.
What is this?
This is so, so sad.
Who are you?
Why is Chico in there?
This is...
At least they didn't put pause, right?
Because that would be even more depressing.
But God...
His face here looks so funny.
Oh, gosh.
Whoo.
I want the...
I want the skull face, kind of.
Wait, no.
That...
I did not...
I did not just see a cage.
I did not just see...
Ah!
This is...
This is so...
Oh, my God.
He's going after that guy.
This is kind of fun.
I like this a lot, actually.
I wonder if it comes with all of this.
This is...
This is wild.
Oh, my God.
I'm crying.
This is so funny.
They know what they were doing.
Oh, my gosh.
I kind of want it so I can put everybody in the cage.
Oh, my God.
I want everybody in the baby jail.
I wish it was still for sale.
Oh, send me back.
When does...
When was this released?
2015.
Send me back.
Oh, this is so...
This whole set is...
Wow.
That's my favorite thing.
Put chat in the cage.
Oh, I will.
Oh, here we go.
It's tiny.
Why is the picture so small?
ChicoChildSoldierPOWVersionChangeCageAndTraumaIncludedPiesStomachBombed.
Oh, my God.
It's so small.
We're getting into, like, the non-metal gear stuff.
Oh, my God.
Oh, Peace Walker.
It's so small.
More Symphogear.
I like...
They came out with these cases.
They had, like, an iDroid case, but they also came out with these, like, actual metal cases.
And I want to get the iDroid one because I see it pretty often for sale.
Imagine a friend enters your room and asks you, why do you have a scale model of a kid in a cage?
I know, right?
Oh, my God.
But, yeah, I don't have any...
I can't justify getting them because I would have to...
I would never be able to use them.
But the iDroid one is so cool.
I was like...
If I...
I don't know.
Mod it or something.
There's no way.
So much Symphogear.
What is Metal Fear?
Metal Fear Notebook.
I don't know.
Do you guys want to see my recently viewed items?
They're at the bottom.
Look at this creepy...
Carby.
Yeah.
Car...
What is this, though?
It says, Metal Gear Notebook 2012 top features.
Four snakes and personal data and Metal Gear appearing in the title.
What does that mean?
Different famous quotes of characters are printed for each day.
Is it just a calendar?
A 2012 calendar?
Seven title stories are summarized.
Many screenshots are used.
Worlds of Metal Gear can be enjoyed with gaming language.
Oh, I love gaming language.
I see you ogling, Ayami.
I'm going to get that.
I'm going to get that, Ayami figure.
Okay.
Last page.
It's all...
It's all Peace Walker.
Oh, wait.
What are these?
I've seen these before.
Yeah, the ultra detail ones.
They look really good, actually.
I do really like these because they have all snakes except Liquid and Solidus.
But, you know.
They'd rather...
They'd rather put a mask over Old Snake than include Liquid in there.
I would kill for MGS4 figures.
These ones you can find occasionally on Mercari.
Yeah, the playable snakes.
There you go.
That's a better way to put it.
What?
They also don't have MGS1 snakes.
Thank you, Mint.
I'm going to pre-order that BAU.
It's good, right?
Oh, sorry.
I instinctively... There's a shiroko and a hoshinoa, so...
Oh, wait.
Is Yuka not up for pre-order?
Oh, she is.
Okay.
I was like, why aren't you... Oh, wow.
There's even more down here.
They're really cute.
They're really, really cute.
I'm kind of debating.
Sudden blue archive.
Okay.
Always blue archive.
Look.
You guys...
When will they invent squishable figures?
Actually, they have.
I have a figure that has...
It's cast off.
It's smaller, but the boobs are squishy.
So why won't they make the tummy squishy too?
Come on.
Pop-up parade.
The formable materials are harder to cast.
It's 2024.
We have to make use of all of our technology.
Is that Big Boss?
Cheerleader Hibiki.
So cute.
Oh my god.
I want to pre-order it.
I'm still deciding if I should or not.
Trying to cut down a little bit.
I really like this toki also.
Or rather...
I want this toki.
But I don't know if I like her face.
There's something about it that doesn't...
There's something off about it.
Especially in this photo.
I don't know.
There's something off about her face.
Not smug enough?
No, toki is not a smug character.
I got a figure with squishy thighs.
There is hope.
Sounds like an idea for future merch.
Squishable Minto figure.
Where would I be squishable at?
Actually don't answer that.
I don't want...
Don't answer that.
Like she looks better in some...
Like this picture she looks good I think.
I don't know.
I think the face is just a little off for me though.
Okay.
We're done.
I'm done window shopping.
Time for real shopping.
Well guys, this was fun.
Thanks for letting me...
Watch that.
Thanks for watching it all together.
Oh, hold on.
I have to put up my advertisements.
I'm so sorry.
Advertisements!
Oh wait, there's supposed to be...
Behind me.
There we go.
Squishy mint figure.
I guess like maybe ectoplasm, right?
The mint stream.
The rare place where...
In the same sitting you view merch of military...
What are you talking about?
We didn't look at any...
Anything that was 18+.
Maybe...
Maybe some stream will...
Will...
Uh...
Shop AmiAmi or something.
We can do something like that.
If you guys would be...
Not shop, but window shop.
If you guys would be interested.
Maybe something like that.
Anyway.
Thank you guys for letting me fan out...
Fan out?
I'm all fanned out.
Fan girl out a little bit.
And also window shop.
While I was looking for...
Snake on AmiAmi.
But he was not there.
So sad.
Tomorrow we'll be playing more Metal Gear.
So...
If you were just like wow.
Not enough Metal Gear today Minto.
Well then you...
Can check us out tomorrow.
I just finished air combat.
About Ace Combat 1.
It was a pain experience.
You did it though.
Nice shirt nerd.
Thank you.
Even though I got scammed.
If you don't know what I mean.
Watch the beginning of the stream.
But yeah.
See you guys tomorrow.
Get some rest.
It's the weekend baby.
It's the weekend party.
Bye bye.
Thank you.
You have face change.
Face changes though.
I will get last.
Okay everybody let Evan have last.
Can you blame me though?
Looking for Free Rin.
They have like the new plushie.
But I don't like Free Rin's eyes.
On the plushie.
So I don't think I...
They have the one where she's in the mimic.
But I don't like the eyes on the plushie.
It's self.
I did it.
It makes me so sad.
I think I pre-ordered a figure.
That is really cute.
I just wish her eyes were different in the plushie.
Goofy but not in a good way.
Oh wow.